thousands of Israelis took to the
streets of Tel Aviv to protest against
the government's economic response to
the corona virus pandemic unemployment
has jumped above 20 percent in the
country since partial lockdown came into
force in March police made 19 arrests
the new normal first register your
personal details and take a temperature
check before you can enter a cafe in
Jerusalem students are on leaf nice for
Eid that the number of coronavirus cases
is once again rising sharply she lost
her part-time job during the lockdown in
March and April now she's facing renewed
uncertainty health issues and the
economic situation students are getting
infected people my age it's not only the
over-60s so it's frightening and
financially I'm still unemployed I still
have to pay my rent on Israel its
borders and imposed a strict lockdown
for several weeks at a cost
unemployment rose from four to more than
20 percent but schools and businesses
started to reopen in May a few weeks ago
it looked like Israel navigated it's
very quite well through the corona
pandemic that has changed dramatically
special Corona wards and hospitals and
drive-through testing centers like this
one had to be reopened these testing
stations had closed because there was no
demand
now cars are lining up again experts are
discussing what went wrong there were no
strategic preparation what will happen
after the lockdown and what we've seen
now is the second wave here Israelis a
result of the inaction during the first
wave and it's unfortunate because we're
one of the few countries which ended the
first wave with 300 death few infections
and we could have revived the economy
very well
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu was
widely praised for his handling of the
crisis first time round that has changed
people are worried about a second wave
new restrictions were announced this
week including increasing fines for not
wearing masks limiting the number of
people in public areas and restaurants
it feels like a deja vu for chef Dan
Schmo Lubitz who had just reopened this
fish restaurant in Tel Aviv you don't
know if you're gonna work tomorrow or
not last time it happened it was very
surprising this time we were more ready
for that but still the uncertainty it's
very confusing another prolonged
lockdown might still be on the cards a
dismal prospect for most Israelis who
thought the worst was already over over
1.8 million people have tested positive
for covered 19 in Brazil that's the
second highest number in the world after
the u.s. more than 70,000 have died and
it's the poor who are most at risk among
them residents of the slums and the
country's indigenous people it's one of
the most remote parts of South America
if not the world
the Yanomami people live in the depths
of the Amazon in Brazil's far north this
is one of the country's largest
indigenous reserves but even here the
fear of the coronavirus is growing we
came to ask for help here to see if we
are well we walk for hours to reach here
[Music]
locals believe the virus was first
brought to the reserve by prospectors
searching for gold the remoteness of
this place increases the danger for the
Yanomami
like access to healthcare services at
the beginning of the month the brazilian
defense ministry organized a fly-in
clinic it's not the constant on ground
presence that indigenous rights groups
have been calling for but the testing is
much needed all the same when we arrived
they were a little bit afraid they
looked at us from afar but then we
gained their trust they came closer it
all went well and it's all been so
rewarding there are hundreds of
indigenous groups living in Brazil and
not all are found in the Amazon Guarani
and be a live on the edge of the
country's biggest city Sao Paulo here to
a community is threatened by the
coronavirus its residents have been
learning how to cope in theory but not
all of the government's advice applies
in practice to those who live communally
there isn't a proper space to recuperate
or to isolate we don't have any of that
and this is what worries us the corona
virus is ravaging South America's
largest country and the fear is that its
peoples like these will be hurt the most
disease added to poverty and
powerlessness a further challenge in
Brazilian indigenous people's struggle
for survival let's give you some other
developments in the krona virus pandemic
new infections in the United States are
still at record highs with more than
60,000 new infections recorded on
Saturday
several states logged record figures
including South Carolina and Hawaii at
least 16 million Mexicans have been
plunged into poverty by the virus that's
according to a new study the number of
Mexicans in extreme poverty has nearly
doubled since February amid widespread
job losses and the wife of Brazilian
President jarba cenario says
she has tested negative for the krona
virus the Brazilian president announced
he had the virus on Tuesday he's
quarantine at home in a separate bedroom
from his wife